what's the button is this the button or
is this the button uh it's like back
here but
when you get knocked out when you're
when you're when it goes like this when
it whips
and also if they can hit back here on
the equilibrium yeah it's bad
how come i heard on the chin that's not
the button
no it's it's shut when your brain goes
when you get hit
and you get your bell rung do you
know like where you are oh yeah it
depends how hard it is but yeah you do
for sure and and
and when you look back on the fight it's
almost like a high is it really yeah
is it harder are things slowing down
is it harder to protect yourself you're
just a little out of it it's
almost like you know when you're like
high almost yeah you're just like a
little
like everything's slower and it's going
to be can you
can you can you when you look back at
the fight
is there a period that you don't
remember oh yeah so there's a chunk of
time where you're like i have no idea
what just happened
yeah why not zig instead of that and
during that time
is your brain working but your body
isn't are you like
are you cognizant of oh this is i'm not
i'm getting the [ __ ]
not really what what's is there anything
it's just like a barrage yeah just back
to like it's weird huh
i can't even like because when i it's
when i hear people like commenters talk
about oh that nfl player is a [ __ ] or
that fighter is a [ __ ]
to me just by nature of you're in the
nfl
or you're you're you're not a [ __ ] no
you may be less tough than some of the
people
in that sport no they're still tough but
they're still tough right made a mistake
like when i hear people call deshawn
jackson not tough i'm like
look man he's not as tough as some other
people
but he didn't maybe he doesn't play with
injury as well just different but the
fact that you
you get his a competitive in an nfl game
he's a monster
i'll tell you something too i would tell
you right now 85
of grown-ups in america or in the world
couldn't take getting whipped down to
the astroturf
just that alone you're being generous at
85. i'd say it's more like 95. just that
just that alone seems like that would
hurt look at corona you think 95 percent
could get
tackled to astroturf think about it
you're right [ __ ]
that won't leave that and then we don't
get started but dude i think people
like that astroturf is basically
pavement it's it's
green pavement and so when you know it's
a little better but when you get thrown
on it
and that whatever i almost would rather
get tackled when i see people get
whipped to the ground i'm like you just
get thrown on the
on the cement my nightmare and no pads
i did have somebody reach out and say
that they played center remember we were
talking about wearing a cup
and he said i played center and i never
he said he never get hit by a cup
never get hit he said most of times this
dude who was listening
said he got hit in the nuts when he hit
himself with the ball yeah
it's very rare there were cups but they
he he said he would hit himself with
yeah
man you hit yourself when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son